i have a lot of sunspots on my face  because i had never taken care of my  skin's health before and so i purchased  these three  sunscreens which i thought were only  sunscreen i actually started off with i  think it's the beige shade and i thought  that it was a little bit too light so i  tried the bronze now what i actually do  is use this for all over the face and  then this more of like a bronzer  and i thought this one was only for lips  and i was like why is it so big and i  realized that you can use it as a blush  so  yeah i totally missed the memo that this  can be used as everyday makeup so  i really like it now i can finally take  care of my skin's health like i should  have from the very beginning